one of my favorite things is getting to
interview full-time content creators
especially those have who have been able
to grow in a short amount of time and on
today's episode of the youtube made
simple show i have rob from rob builds
and i can't wait for you to hear his
five tips for new youtubers
welcome to the youtube made simple show
my name is heather torres author of the
book youtube made simple coming out in
the beginning of 2022
and i'm excited because on today's
episode of this show i have rob from rob
builds if you are in the short-term
rental space if you're into tiny homes
or you're into understanding how to
start a short-term rental airbnb
business you've definitely come across
rob from rob builds now let me tell you
a little bit about rob rob has been a
real estate investor in the short-term
rental space for the last four years he
recently quit his six-figure job in
advertising to pursue a career as a
content creator and full-time real
estate investor in january of 2020 he
started the rob builds youtube channel
where he showcases his tiny places and
unique spaces to an audience of over a
hundred and twenty-five thousand
subscribers as of today rob owns 14
short-term rental properties with plans
to double his real estate portfolio
within the next year and plans to grow
his youtube business even more so let's
get into today's episode with rob built
[Music]
rob i'm so excited that you're here for
the youtube made simple show and we're
going to be diving into your advice your
five tips for people who are starting on
youtube as advice from a new full-time
youtuber i say new because you just quit
your job you're full-time on youtube now
and this is actually going to be one of
a two-part series that we're doing here
on the show where we're just
highlighting different creators who are
full-time and really diving into their
stories and you know how are they
actually making a living on and off of
youtube so rob welcome to the show
hi hi i'm so excited to be here it's
like it's so full circle for me because
like think was like literally the first
youtube channel like that that is the
inception of the rob hilt channel so
thanks for having me on i am so excited
i've been watching you for several years
now um
all the way back to your first uh you
know tour my tiny home uh video so i'm
excited but the audience why don't you
tell them a little bit about who you are
and how you became full-time on youtube
sure well my name is rob
recently just changed my name not like
legally or anything like that but uh my
name is robert and then when i started
my channel everyone started calling me
rob and so i was like okay i guess i'm
wrong now uh so i started a youtube
channel in january of 2020 so just over
like 20 months ago yeah about that's how
my daughter was born in the month that i
started my channel so 20 months ago i
started a youtube channel
and you know for me when i started out i
was just like look i just want to make
enough money from adsense to buy a
chipotle burrito and if i could get some
free power tools that would be awesome
because i started out as a diy channel
and i was just grinding like every day
editing like two two or three in the
morning i'm not a good editor um and i
was just doing that every day and my
goal was to hit a thousand subscribers
and like to the day on month six i hit a
thousand subscribers and i was like wow
i did it like my dream came true
and i was like all right next goal five
thousand it's gonna be a rough couple
years to get there it's gonna be a lot
of work but i'm like so excited and then
one of my videos took off and i got like
5 000 subscribers that next week and
then a week after that i was at 25 000
subscribers and that was really for me
uh around the time let's see that was
in july and youtube made me a crater on
the rise for a day and that was like a
life-changing time for me that's when i
was like oh my goodness like this is
cool i think i think i want to do this
forever and fast forward to today um i'm
about
120 000 subscribers
in and i put content out every single
week i teach people how to build tiny
houses how to start airbnb businesses
real estate finance uh personal
confessionals about what's going on in
my life and everything in between and uh
now i guess i'm on podcast every so
often so
now you're a podcasting youtuber isn't
that amazing
um yes i love back to where you said
those first beginner videos i remember
you'd have like those chipotle uh images
that would come up um in your videos so
it's so cool to see that now you can
afford a chipotle right
yeah
youtube videos i now can get like the
the double meat on the chipotle and not
not stressed so much yeah we always said
uh when shawn and i were building think
media we win the day we can ask for
guacamole and not blink
that was our that was you know because
extra guacamole costs a little bit more
so
all jokes aside i really do feel that
way because my wife and i we live out in
tennessee right now and we went out to
chipotle and i was like what do you want
she's like pablo and she's like get isla
a a quesadilla and then i bought it and
i sat down and i was like i didn't even
stress that i had to spend an extra six
dollars on this quesadilla i was like we
did it babe like we're gonna be okay yup
yup i know that feeling well uh now that
you are a full-time youtuber i wanted to
talk really about the real advice um
because you were a student of youtube
you were really studying but really it
was you know you get bits and pieces
from different people but i love that
you did a video where you were helping
people learn how to start on youtube and
i took five pieces from that video and i
want to dive into them the first one you
said is you don't actually have to be a
pro
when you get started let's talk about
that a little bit more because you
weren't technically a pro on youtube you
just picked up a camera and started
sharing your story
yeah i picked up the best camera in the
market which is the the camera that you
have on you i can't see it on here and
that was my iphone that's what i started
with um and honestly it was just i was i
had always wanted to start a youtube
channel and for whatever reason i just
had i mean for like 10 years since
college i just never had a concept or
anything like that and i was like what
would people even like want to hear me
talk about and i'd done so much diy
when i like before starting a youtube
channel that so many people are like you
should start a channel so i was like all
right well you know i want to be like
the homemade modern or like modern
builds youtube channels which were my
favorites and so like i kind of just
started that way and i was like all
right well this iphone um
10 or whatever it was iphone x it's got
4k on it that's awesome like that's
that's as good as it gets in the market
i really had no idea and so yeah i mean
i just started off very rough with
imovie on an iphone
and i was recording on my iphone for
probably the first 15 20 videos on my
channel just because you know i thought
you know that was that was really good i
was like this is good it's like an
iphone how bad could it be
and
i really i got a canon m50 like six
months into my youtube journey and
that's kind of when i was like all right
i think i'm gonna be a youtuber now it
really was just honestly watching y'all
i was like what is the the entry level
like vlogging camera and like think
media had all the reviews on it and
stuff like that omar did a bunch of
content on i was like all right cool
like i guess that's what i'm gonna get
and that's when i really to me
made that commitment to myself to become
like this is when i was like this is
going to be my thing you know rain or
shine when i got a camera that was like
my present to myself for like the
hundreds of hours that i put in and also
if i'm being honest i was just tired of
getting like footage off of my iphone
onto my computer that was like a real
real real just like pain painful process
for me so i was like babe please can i
like use our credit card points to get
this camera and she's like yeah i don't
care why do you always ask me i'm like
because i'm like so cheap and i just had
to like really talk myself into it so i
would say for me when i got started
iphone and really the first investment
that i made in the first investment that
i tell anyone before they buy a camera
is get a decent mic i got like a decent
lav mic and i really was trying not to
let equipment and all that stuff get in
the way of it because it was so fun i
was just like whatever's easy whatever i
needed to like make my process of
filming easier for me that's what i was
really going for so i got like a little
tripod i got a mic and that was really
just i forgot about it for the first you
know several like for the first six
months i equipment was like the last
thing i wanted to deal with i just
wanted to be on camera and i wanted to
you know do it well and i wanted to be
funny and i wanted to have funny editing
and i wanted to build cool things for
other people so ultimately for me like
it just came down to
what's the fastest easiest way that i
can create content and that's why i
ended up upgrading because
uploading footage from my phone was no
longer allowing me to create content and
edit it and get it out you know on any
kind of schedule
yeah and you know even talking about
just
being someone who just wanted to create
um did were you afraid at all about not
actually being a pro like the idea of
that this was kind of the first time you
had made videos you weren't you didn't
your career wasn't in construction at
the time right you weren't in um in that
you were just sharing the journey of you
building the tiny home you having real
estate investments and those types of
things were you scared about getting
started
i mean there's like i kind of come from
a tough place in that because i was in
advertising and so i was a creative
copywriter that that was my day job
and i was like you know part of i was
like editing you know million dollar
type of videos right or like half a
million dollar videos but they looked
really good and we spend
months and months in months like putting
together a concept and bidding out
directors and all for like 15 seconds
you know
and it's like an amazing 15 seconds and
so when i started my channel really what
scared me was like man i'm never
ever gonna live up to the work that i
actually created at work right
but ultimately like honestly i was just
more scared about what
people would think more than anything
which is kind of silly obviously and we
all go through it but like i actually
didn't tell anybody that i started a
channel uh when i when i first started
the raw build channel like i just made a
video i told my best friend and you know
he was very supportive he's like dude
this is so you this is great you know my
very first video which is still up i
would never take that down it's very bad
but um
but it's me and that's all that matters
but uh yeah so i was a little nervous
about just like
it's because like i'm very self-aware
and i i just knew like my first videos
were gonna be bad you know and i was
just like man i don't wanna like
i i know what i know what they will be
and they're not there yet and until
they're where where i want them to be i
don't want people to like see how bad my
videos were
and i didn't tell anybody
and i remember like
i made my second video uh which was just
like another diy video and i was like
you know what i'm going to post it to
reddit and just see i'm just going to do
it whatever who cares i like this video
i think it'll do well on the diy
subreddit and i posted it and it made it
to the front page of the subreddit and
it had like 3 400 upvotes and i got like
12 000 views in a day and i remember
just being like oh like oh my gosh i
went viral you know like just that that
first dopamine hit that a youtuber gets
and that to me was
a little bit of confirmation i mean i
got a lot of like haters in the reddit
comments but i also got like a lot of
nice people that were like hey dude
you know not great but you're you're
gonna do great you're gonna do great
keep doing this you know a lot of nice
comments and
just i got so much affirmation from that
that i was like you know
i don't think i need to hide that i'm a
youtuber anymore like why do i even why
am i even doing that and so
i remember i just like i for a long time
my instagram handle was rob asolo it's
just like a combination of my first and
last name and that really felt like
changing your your instagram handle is
like when you have it for 10 years it's
you know it's a serious it's a serious
decision and i remember that day i was
like i'm gonna do it i'm gonna tell
people and i posted it to my instagram
channel and i posted to facebook and i
was like i've got an announcement
i've decided to start a youtube channel
it's called raw built as of today on
instagram you'll now know me as rob
built and all this stuff
and you know
people were so nice like all my friends
and my family were nice i mean you know
it just i'm honestly just a little
choked up because like
i was just like i was like man i guess i
don't suck you know and and that was
like for me the inception of like okay
my friends are on board everyone knows i
have to do this now because i put it out
there and so i i think that really at
the end of the day when you're starting
a youtube channel you'll just literally
never know what can happen to your life
until you put yourself out there
especially on youtube oh such good
advice and you know um for an upcoming
book that i have coming out i
interviewed over a hundred different
creators and eighty percent of them said
i didn't want to tell anyone i started
my youtube channel and i'm thinking why
like tell the world because look at what
happens people want to support what
you're creating and it's so awesome that
when you finally step out and you make
that change and you're like no this is
what i'm going to do it may not be the
full-time thing that i'm doing but it's
the thing i'm creating on the side you
do have people in your life that are
supportive and it's the accountability
to keep creating um so that you are
always in that creative mode so uh
number two rob uh you said is to become
a student of youtube now you did come
from a background in advertising so you
kind you definitely understood
advertising and marketing but was
youtube something that you needed to
learn or was that something that was
already a part of your world
i mean
conceptually it was part of my world but
not not really i mean youtube is its own
game and its own processes and its own
social best practices and stuff so
there was just like a lot that i that i
felt like i needed to learn and that i
still like need to learn and then i
still like i still watch you know think
media videos i still watch catherine
manning videos and film booth videos and
channel makers like all those channels
if i see a video pop up on like the my
algorithm i watch it because i'm always
like all right what do these people have
to say about what's going on because i'm
not necessarily
in the science of youtube and like
reading the articles i don't have like
alerts on and i'm not like oh algorithm
change it's time to change it up like i
just rely on content like yours right to
really inform me on that but you know
it's been a very interesting curve
because like i'm i'm in this now where
like when i started all i did was
consume how to start a youtube video or
how to start a youtube channel
but you know it's like all the same like
a lot of times it's very similar content
out there because it's like there's one
there's not one way to do it but there
are like best practices right
and so for me
i was always just exploring new channels
that had like an interesting twist on it
or like something different that's kind
of why like think even is great because
there you all have like a lot of
one-hour two-hour videos that you're
just forced to talk in excruciating
detail about youtube whereas in a
10-minute video it's like here are my
five tips and it's like have a good
thumbnail have a good title
be 10 minutes long and it's like well
okay you know there's like i know that
but yeah i mean i think when you're
starting out like it really is about
like studying it to the point that it
hurts you know study everything you can
about youtube
get on like you know the the the
subreddit um youtubers get on small
youtubers boost on on facebook the group
and just like see what other people are
doing watch good content watch bad
content watch
so so content because no matter what
even if the content's not great
someone might have one joke or one
piece of advice or one something that
makes you think oh my god i thought they
were gonna go here with that
and it would have been so great if they
did i'll just do that you know like i
get a lot of inspiration for my content
especially from an editing standpoint or
from you know anything just by watching
channels that i like and i'm like oh
that they missed this point i'm gonna
like really do that or like i wish they
would have done this with the edit but
hey i'm glad they didn't because now i
can or whatever so i don't think you
should ever
ever stop being like
so inundated in the actual craft of
being a youtuber
yeah and a lot of times people will say
um this sentence i don't have enough
time and i'm like stop watching netflix
stop watching hulu like study the study
youtube like if you're going to go into
this and you want it to be part of your
either business or you want to shift
careers or whatever you want that to
look like it won't just happen by you
experimenting it will happen when you
know the basic principles i love how you
said like really you could watch all
these things and people people are
really saying the same thing because
there are basic principles to how the
algorithm on youtube works and it's not
just the algorithm it's understanding
human psychology why do people want to
watch why why have i watched every
single upload of raw builds because i
love the editing because the information
is good because you understand how to
deliver good content and i think you can
see that because you've been studying
youtube so i love that you said that but
i'm like please just stop watching
netflix and watch youtube
well i also think that you want to like
you have to really break your own like
comfort level and like you know back in
the day like a 40 minute video or like a
30 minute video like someone sends you
that you're like annoyed you're like
i'm not going to watch this are you
crazy that's 30 minutes but now honestly
like the most
in like insightful content i watch on
youtube is a minimum of like 20 minutes
a lot of the times so if i see something
that's got like a 40 minute time stamp
from a creator that i like i'm like all
right let's do this thing because
you know i want to know how they're
going to keep me like
captured into that content for 40
minutes straight and so i think it's
like not just studying the actual craft
of youtube but studying people what do
you like about peter mckinnon what do
you like about graham stefan what do you
like about these types of guys like why
do you always watch them and try to use
that to put your own spin on your
content
i love that
and uh next number three is um your
advice is to give it a year man so many
people
end projects way too early they end in
this beginning phase and i always equate
it to the idea of you know when you
plant a seed you don't just all of a
sudden sprout a tree it's going to take
a little bit of time while that's being
watered and the roots are going down and
there the nutrients is going in and then
it sprouts up so your advice to uh new
youtubers is to give it a year why
i mean
i honestly would say give it a year
minimum i think before you start a
youtube channel if you really want to
start a youtube channel
sit down and ask yourself like am i
gonna do this whether i become a youtube
star or a viral celebrity
and if your answer is like
no i mean i just i don't want people to
get into it thinking like it's gonna
happen overnight because honestly it
doesn't
like it happens for some people on year
two on year three on year four i mean
catherine manning i think had like a
channel for like two years before she
became like the huge youtube like coach
that she is today right and so
i think a year
will really at least tell you
like how much you love youtube because i
think you can do it for a year and have
no success
and still say man but i love it
and if you do then you can keep going
for another year or another t or
whatever you want to commit to yourself
but if you do it for a year and you
don't really have a lot of success and
you're like well not only am i not
having success but i actually hate this
then you know to stop but i don't really
think you know
if like i don't know i just don't think
you really know until you give it like a
fair shake and like so many people
like that want to start channels i'm
like give me a year do not say like if
you're not viral in three months or four
months or five like
you know you don't like don't stress
because it doesn't happen like that for
most people it does for some lucky
people obviously but i think just like a
year really just
it teaches you a lot about yourself it
really makes you a better communicator
in general it teaches you a lot about
editing and punching holes through
creative concepts and like it really
just kind of like sets the foundation
for like whether or not you love the
lifestyle um now granted i think you
know if you do this for two months and
you genuinely just don't like
creating a youtube channel and all you
know you don't like creating content you
don't like editing and you don't like
writing titles and thumbnails and you
genuinely just despise it then yeah quit
in a day quit in two weeks whatever but
i think if you genuinely love youtube
and you're like man
no matter what i love i love making
videos even if it gets one two three
hundred you know views on it then i
think you should just keep going
like forever um if you're not seeing the
success that you want to see in a year
or in two years then you know
go back and reevaluate your content and
like take a look at it see your journey
you know i still watch my own videos
like uh that they just loop in my living
room no i'm just kidding um i go back
and i like
just i'll check in on like first video
middle video like i have seasons on
youtube on my playlist like season one
season two season three
and i just like i just it's not a time
it's not like every two months it's a
new season it's just when i feel
that i've graduated to the next level of
of youtube like from a production
standpoint from a quality standpoint i'm
on season three right now and i think
that really fits for where i'm at season
three of the raw belt channel and so i
think you really have to examine your
your content and look at it and say like
what how have i evolved in a year and if
you really don't see much evolution
instead of quitting then like consider
changing up how you do your content how
you put it out there and and really kind
of like
have some critical like you know have a
critical conversation with yourself of
like this isn't working but here's what
i can do and look to you know channels
like a lot of the youtube channels out
there and see how they're doing it and
look at your favorite creators and see
if maybe you can cop their style for a
bit to evolve yours a little bit but at
a minimum
too long didn't watch tldw
i think you got to give it a year if
you're serious about starting a youtube
career minimum yeah and you know with
with a year um
what we teach here at think media is
really understanding and studying your
analytics and unless you've got enough
content out there you don't really have
something to judge it against you can't
really see what your audience retention
rate is or over a certain amount of
videos or compare certain topics that
you're doing to see you know wow when i
talk about this topic i'm getting a max
you know view duration people are
watching all the way through but when i
talk about this
like giving it a year
what i like to teach students is really
focus on your outputs and not on the
numbers don't focus necessarily so much
on the amount of subscribers or the
amount of views it really is like when
you start going to the gym for the first
time which i don't do you would like
you'd feel them you'd feel it right and
so you're not doing the same type of
workouts in a year that you do when you
first start so you've got to just be you
know on that treadmill wow look at this
analogy i'm just taking it far now
you've got to be pulling on the
treadmill
uh to to really actually start to see
the results and you're right you do have
to fall in love with it because this
isn't something you just do and then you
stop youtube is something that can build
your personal brand for years and years
and years to come
all right rob so if you're getting value
out of this while you're watching on
youtube go ahead and let us know down
below so far what has been your uh
favorite piece of advice from rob and
let me know how long have you been on
youtube let me know in the comment
section below and let us know your
favorite chipotle order like are you a
bowl person a burrito person a salad
person what are you rob
uh burrito like burritos what like like
what makes me the happiest in life is
like just a chipotle burrito
but you know if i'm like
if i'm like trying to be healthy i'll
get a bowl but it makes me sad so i'll
just say a burrito that's like i'm happy
just think i want to go get a burrito
after this i went yesterday and i want
to go again today so i mean leave us a
comment down below yes you've got to
know i i'm definitely a bowl person and
really i was doing the salads for a
while but it's so much lettuce i'm like
do we need this much lettuce it's not
it is but it makes me feel better it
does and they're chips oh man the amount
of salt on their chips is heavenly so
um
it really is so good
oh you're making me hungry now all right
uh number four is to embrace the suck
this is talking about the bad comments
or the videos that don't perform i think
whenever you get into anything
especially if you're trying to win on
youtube you have to know that there's
going to be some high highs like when
you get that viral video but there's
also going to be low lows when someone
doesn't like the content you're creating
or you put a ton of time time and effort
into a video and it just kind of bombs
it doesn't really go anywhere or the one
that you never thought would have gotten
picked up by the algorithm is the one
that is always getting the views so rob
talk about how you embrace the suck uh
on youtube
yeah totally i mean oh man there's so
many good good pieces on in this like
first of all like with haters and all
that kind of so let's just talk about
that because i think
well i was in advertising so genuinely
like
people were like this is not a good idea
come back with 10 more and i was already
used to like that type of criticism
relatively thick skin that really primed
me for youtube so genuinely i don't
really get
like hurt by comment so i have a little
bit of an unfair advantage but if you're
the kind of person that you're a little
sensitive
you got to be ready you got to be ready
for the mean comments because people
will comment on how your hair looks like
a toupee
people will comment on
you know how you're how you have a
punchable face
people will comment on yeah there's so
many things right
oh gosh now i want to cry no um
and so like that's fine so
i think you have to really remember that
in my opinion i mean i don't know maybe
they're science maybe you can dispel
this uh myth here but i personally think
that youtube likes a little bit of uh
controversy if you will like they want
some level of like kind of dissonance in
the comment section when i first posted
my like one of my first really really
big viral videos was inside my 165 000
tiny house so it's this juxtaposition of
a tiny house that costs 165 000
so a lot of people are like oh my god
dream house i've always wanted to live
in a tiny house that looks like this and
then the other side is like oh my god
you're such an idiot for spending so
much money on a tiny house and so that
type of like com those types of comments
really clash quite a bit in the comments
section people argue with each other
people make fun of me and then
commenters will defend me and it's like
a whole thing and then youtube's like
hey
this video that rob posted is causing
people to stay on his video for 20
minutes and then they come back for
another 10 minutes to argue meaning
they're not going on reddit facebook
instagram tick tock let's keep promoting
this right and so
you have to remember
bad comments good comments mediocre
comments
they help you with your engagement uh
you're gonna have like like a bad
comment when someone leaves me like
like a very long bad comment i'm just
like thank you thank you for spending 10
minutes writing that because youtube
registers that as a good thing so that's
kind of like the one thing like don't be
don't be bummed like see the positive
side of bad comments uh number two
when you get a bad comment
my favorite response i mean this is
really just like my go-to if someone
just totally just rips me a new one i
just heart it
that's my favorite thing sometimes i'll
pin a bad comment like if it's like a
really mean one i'll be like i'll pin it
to like the top of my video and i just
think that's kind of like a funny thing
because sometimes like i'll get caught
up thinking about what's like a clever
response and i'll be like you know i'm
just going to heart it and like
i'm not going to say half the time i'll
say like 25 of the time people will
delete the comment because i'll go back
to like show my wife or whatever and i
like click on reply and then it's like
gone and i'm like come on um
cowards no uh but yeah so i think
whether you get bad comments just like
brush it off heart it move on hug a
hater kind of thing in terms of like the
ups and downs of youtube that's like a
very very real thing i mean imagine this
you get a hundred thousand subscribers
your your life goal comes true and
you're like i've done it i've arrived
i've hit my big goal and then
the next like four or five videos just
tank and you get like a seven out of ten
an eight out of ten a nine out of ten
and a ten out of ten that's what
happened to me like as soon as i hit a
hundred thousand subscribers i was like
we're on baby and then like all of my
videos were just a little slow like
after that and i was like man i remember
i was like
no way really why i figured youtube
might hook it up a little bit you know
and so like remember texted my my buddy
um eric floreberg if you've ever seen
his channel great guy and i was like
dude
i can't believe this and i sent him like
my video that was like a 10 out of 10.
he's like yep it's a dry season man
don't sweat it and even now at where i
am in my career on youtube i still get
bummed about that kind of thing because
i'm like or i'm still getting nervous
i'm like mate have i
has the expiration date on the raw build
channel come am i a has been and like
i'm always bummed and then right after
that you know you launch a series or you
launch a video that just totally does
well and that's exactly what happened
like after four
videos
like the next set after that hit the
algorithm and i did really really great
and i you know i texted my
my buddy
who also has a smaller youtube channel
and i was like complaining he was like
dude like 4 000 views in your first 24
hours is like i would kill for that he's
like i get like 30. you know i'm like
have to remember the perspective here
you have to remember where you came i
mean even just like where you came from
like i just posted a video last week
that i've i really liked it it's called
i just i just filmed a tv pilot thinking
oh you know
my my subscribers are going to love this
and it's 10 out of 10 for me and i was
just like i was a little bummed because
i was like come on i got a pilot like
you would think people would respond to
this
but then i was like i don't know like 4
000 views in a day like man i would have
like for like from subscribers zero to
like 80 000 i was like so like that
would have been a dream come true and so
you just always have to put things into
perspective this is kind of why i say
give it a year because
you know you want to look at at your
growth and you want to compare your
views now to like when you first started
and you know at the end of the day when
you have a little bit of perspective i
think it really it really makes you feel
a lot better about your channel
yeah and you know again the piece about
youtube is that it's all about what your
subscribers want to watch it's what
youtube wants to serve up and suggested
it's what's coming up in search i mean
there's so many variables every time you
post a video that really it's about we
what we say here is about the base hits
it's about not always trying to shoot
for the home run but just knowing that
that steady amount of views four
thousand like four can you imagine like
four thousand people just like showed up
at your house that's insane when you
think about you know four thousand um
and so yeah it is it's all about the
perspective of it but youtube does we
have lulz too and for us we take that as
kind of the
kobe bryant approach you know every game
that kobe bryant played he didn't go
home after he watched the game tape
because he was like i want to see every
little nuance that i did and that's for
us where we start diving into the
analytics and really figuring out man
every time heather leaves the screen and
a screen share comes up people leave
okay well let's not do that like it just
allows us to really figure out more and
more um what people like what youtube
likes and understanding that there are
dry seasons like we we were in a meeting
uh not too long ago because our numbers
were down well they were down because
the pandemic had made our numbers up so
it was that whole idea of you know okay
are we really down no when we when we
looked at it over a two year span this
was a normal occurrence on our channel
because of the season because of the
things and so we were fine but again it
does kind of play with your mind a
little on you know you just have to know
that not everything you're it's not that
song everything i do is win right you're
not always winning there's always gonna
be um the pieces that do suck all right
lastly rob
uh is remember your fans i love that you
had this as a piece of advice for
youtubers because
even just piggybacking off of what we
just talked about um as we grow we are
and growth already just means that we're
looking for new i want more people i
want more people but man the people that
have been there since the beginning the
people that like i know are commenting
on our stuff like becca is always on our
comments like i just know her and i love
her because she's always there i love
that you said as you're growing your
advice is to always remember your fans
talk about that a little bit and how
that's helped you grow on youtube
yeah i mean i think you know i
i don't as much as i used to just
because it's it obviously becomes harder
the more comments you get in but i try
to like comment back and like respond to
people and all that kind of stuff but i
i try to make it a point to respond
definitely to people that are like
pretty consistent commenters
people that always ask questions people
that always say nice things
and i would hope that they know that i
do remember them and i try to like shout
them out every so often or you know and
and like there are a couple of people on
my channel that i know i can count on
that you know they will they will
comment on my videos and i'm always like
yeah so i always try to respond to them
and like show them a little love because
they take the time to like you know sit
back and like watch my content and then
you know for a lot of people it is very
inconvenient to comment like
for me
like 99
of youtube that i watch is on my tv so
it is very inconvenient for me to
comment on a video and if i like really
like the creator or the content i will
go walk over to my laptop and i'll hey
and i'll even say like hey i i was
watching this on the tv and i walked
over to my laptop to leave this just to
let you know that i really liked this
video or whatever you know and so i i
really do appreciate people that do that
kind of thing because i know and you
know i also notice whenever like those
those people disappear and i'm always
like where's jill's comment ted i hope
everything's okay and then like two
weeks later i'll get like three comments
on she's like hey sorry i just missed
the last three videos or she's like you
know she actually just commented
yesterday she's like catching up sorry
the last three weeks are crazy and she
left comments on every single one and i
was like this is what i'm talking about
you know i love that
though rob fans that are like hey sorry
i wasn't here like i wouldn't you know
isn't that crazy to think though like
fit like jill was like hey sorry i'm
just catching up that that she has such
a relationship with you that she would
tell you that right and that's the like
oh yeah so good sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt but i just had to make it oh
yeah i agree i think i think that to me
is like really great and you know jill i
know that she like signed up for my
glamp camp which was like one of my
programs and she was active in that and
so yeah if someone like
comments or they comment something very
nice i'll definitely like try to go in
and be like if they're like oh my god
you're like my favorite youtuber i'll be
like you're literally my favorite
commenter thank you so much for always
like supporting these videos and i think
that goes a really long way because
you know return you like return visitors
is like a really important thing on
youtube but so is just like having like
the more people that you can build that
loyalty with and make them feel special
the more often they're going to comment
and the more comment you get is the more
engagement that you get and that
ultimately plays in to like the
performance of a lot of your videos so i
think it's important to try to nurture
your audience in a way that you know
makes them feel special a little bit
yeah and as you grow it does get harder
you mentioned that and we we've
experienced this here at think uh you
know our inbound now with the amount of
views that we're getting and just the
programs that we have our amount of
inbound we actually hire full-time
people
to help us now because it's just so much
and one thing that we always preach here
at think is do what you would for one
what you wish you could do for many and
so i'll spend 30 minutes every day just
in the comments or in our programs or
sending dms back you know because it
just starts coming in from all these
different places but one thing to
remember if you are starting on youtube
be who you want on your channel meaning
are you commenting on other people's
stuff are you engaging in the community
because if you're asking people to do it
for you you should be doing it as well
to be a leader in what you're doing so i
love rob that you said like even if
you're watching on your tv you'll make a
point to go over and uh and make that
comment well
and i i really do get on my wife and
like anyone who's in my house that watch
youtube videos especially if they're
long like something like a tutorial and
be like did you like it and they're like
no i didn't even think about it i'm like
you literally just watched that for 30
minutes and they taught you how to like
weave a basket out of yarn
like they taught you something go like
it and they're always like okay okay
sorry you know we got to educate the
people on youtube rob that's what we're
trying to do um i'm so grateful for you
for being on this this is part one we're
actually gonna go into uh part two on
next week's episode where we're gonna be
talking about how you just quit your job
and went full time on youtube so we're
gonna talk about the steps that you had
to take to get to that and what that
actually means to be a quote-unquote
full-time youtuber now that's on your
new resume or if you even want a resume
you don't even have to have a resume
anymore i threw it away
all right i like uh put it in my garbage
and then i deleted my garbage on my
computer yeah yeah so we're gonna be
talking about that but rob if people
want to find you they want to become
part of the tribe that you're creating
on youtube where can they find you um
all over on the web
well obviously they can smash the
subscribe button on the raw built
youtube channel
many people think it's row built it
looks like that it's r-o-b-u-i-l-t
you can follow me on instagram uh rob
built there as well and unfortunately
someone snagged raw built for me on tick
tock so i'm rob bilto on tick tock so
you can find me on those three other
other than that
like a carrier pigeon you know i've got
i've got that rocket and rolling if you
want to send me like a a cute little
bird with a little tiny scroll
i love it well thank you so much for
being on the show today rob
yeah of course thanks for having me are
you ready to start or grow your youtube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
you